hi i'm drew hi i'm things and we are
going to talk red flag green flag now
tinks kim kardashian and pete davidson
what are the red flags what are the
green flags i think green flags i think
that he really brings out her funny side
very humorous it's light-hearted seems
like they're having a good time who
doesn't want that red flag
um
you know they have slightly different
street styles but that's okay you know
they have different looks soon pete will
be wearing balenciaga head to toe and
i'm excited for that i'm into the
balenciaga look okay justin bieber and
hayley bieber green flag so many green
flags i feel like they started as
friends and like their relationship is
so solid because they're just best
friends and they have just so many core
values in common no they really share
the love like they are a couple girls
all the way red flag i don't think they
have anybody no i can't think of any
either
um hard to keep up with maybe yeah
that's a red flag to everybody else